il s'appelle roger figeant il a 76 ans
et c'est un grand inventeur c'est
l'inventeur du plongeur
le plongeur est un ustensile incroyable
qui permet de nettoyer les grosses
tâches qui colle aux casseroles rien
qu'en tournant la main intéressant donc
inventé c'est ustensiles n'a pas été
facile pour nous ce pigeon il lui a
fallu quinze ans de recherche
ciao que je ne suis pas tellement
adroits pour trouver les solutions
et pourtant il en a fait des scènes
issues fusion il en a créé des
prototypes de toutes sortes des
centaines de récurrent de casseroles il
a testé il a dessiné il en est fabriqué
en bois en plastique et tout ça j'ai
commencé par des savarières ressort à
jean minier avec des carrés au bout
après ça j'en ai eu comme ça pour
tourner autour des casseroles après ça
j'ai fait des choses et gilles j'ai
essayé avec des ressorts d'accueil j'en
ai fait avec des pinces de cette façon
on en est si j'en ai comme cela et tout
ça pour en arriver à ça et je me
schaeffer
bravo bravo monsieur bel objet ça donne
envie d'être une casserole tellement
c'est bien